[Music]
maybe we should just start with a bit of
a cruiser
for you what do you mean
what does that mean break it out let's
do a key right now
we're just going to start slow it's a
cruiser quick bump
okay pull my necklace out just
go ahead
nah um
sucked off session
succession oh yeah oh my god so [ __ ]
good so
in in preparation for the new season i
watched the past two
well kelsey was gone last week she was
at a bachelorette party so that helped
all i did was watch succession the whole
time
and uh to get ready for this season so i
crushed two seasons in like five days
that's a lot yeah acting is amazing it
is the best show on television by far
it's the best show ever made when when
we were watching it like watching this
episode having not watched any
succession is just picking up on all
like the subtle business slang that they
use it's like sometimes like you take a
step back from it it just sounds [ __ ]
crazy like the first scene that they use
in the recap like all right what do you
think about this bear hug yeah do we
fight it or do we pinch it's like what
poison pill yeah they're like oh [ __ ]
off yeah it's like oh i'm talking about
like corporate espionage and [ __ ] yeah
damn
uh i just yeah i don't know there's
something
it's just so much fun about watching
these people operate knowing that money
is just not an object yeah for them at
all yeah what i'm saying anything they
want like logan's like in trouble so
he's like all right get me on the phone
with like the five best law firms in the
states we'll just hire them all the
planes they fly in getting sick you
probably can't get it up anymore
oh [ __ ] off you think logan roy's dick
still works yeah he can [ __ ] for sure i
don't think so yeah remember in when he
like woke up from a stroke and he was
recovering he tried to put shiv's his
own daughter's hand down his pants oh
that's right power move yeah
power move yeah power move to get jerked
off by your daughter yeah
that was the power move right there for
sure i want you to jerk me off this must
be the stroke talking i'm totally fine
i'll show you stroke commission oh jesus
christ
no
no logan yeah i think he gets down him
and marcia
no she walked out on that she laughed
she dumped yeah
but i think he was piping raya for a bit
yeah
which is wild because like she seems so
much younger
than him yeah you know it seems like
kind of a guilt
they're going to say i feel like roman
you know i thought you could say
a kill ceo i'd like to [ __ ]
um anyways the new episode was [ __ ]
fantastic do you think kendall's going
to do it i think he's in a manic state
right now that's what i think yeah same
right all that [ __ ] all that they're
building towards is him completely
crashing and shiv because i think shiv
is taking his side when she was leaving
the
oh yeah she when like roman like dogged
her out for not getting the position or
whatever and she's like telling her she
[ __ ] up with lisa and she was like you
know what megan make a turn i think that
she's going to kendall and she's going
to join his side because her name is
shiv
yeah
oh yeah
yeah it was in front of us the whole
time yeah
that's a good point i do love
how like it's pretty comical
how
they're always vying to be the ceo and
how many instances just over
the three seasons now
of logan just being like roman's out
shiv's out yeah this person's out yeah
like everyone's always out yeah and he
can't make up his [ __ ] mind yeah
okay and he yeah
he'll never be able to that's the thing
and kendall also looks like such a [ __ ]
like his weird reassurances are so lame
how do i go to these [ __ ] smart women
around me
yeah
you're asking the dumbest guy in the
room that yeah oh yeah you're doing
awesome kendall that's a good impression
thanks a good great
that was really good like yeah my
[ __ ] my [ __ ] killing it or what
i'm killing it right yeah okay okay i'll
talk to you in a second greg
[Music]
lisa you have my undivided attention i
want to [ __ ] work with you he is
pretty cringe isn't he and his wife the
whole time i'm gonna watch this [ __ ]
she's like oh he's melting down again
yep
yep
yeah pretty uncomfortable
this is rava
uh this is the stable woman that left me
[Laughter]
observing a brown woman watch
her dude melt down was a little too
close to home for me
i was like yeah i don't like
the subtle parallels here
elena's like this shell's great i'm like
let's [ __ ]
oh watch king of the hill okay
that's funny no i'm the smartest guy in
the house when we put on king of the
hill [ __ ] this show
yeah i think kendall's definitely in a
manic state but i feel there's a lot of
people also all the people trying to
like
get into his money
he's like said all that crazy [ __ ] about
social media and the social media rats
like yeah sure whatever dude we want to
work with you yeah i know but i think
they think that he's gonna win yeah i
don't think they're really taking
advantage
that's what that was the impression i
got i feel like everybody were like if
just just in the small chance that this
guy actually ends up taking over the
company it's gonna be huge for us yeah
that's fair but i still feel like that's
them trying to get something
yeah yeah it is but that's business
no i know
deep bro mic drop baby how's the
business where's that [ __ ] ipad
you know what i mean
we need a button where that thing just
comes around and hits me in the face i
just feel like that's why kendall's not
a real killer
but he is now no see that's i don't know
if that's the thing i don't know if he
is dude i know
cause like it it's all like it's all
theater he's not like the killer you
know like he doesn't walk in the room
and everyone's like what he did to his
dad that was crazy press conference that
was a killer move he killed his dad yeah
he killed him yeah that was the
finishing blow yeah and that was the
whole point
he didn't even realize that he made his
son a killer a savage
you know what i mean
he's never going to pick that like
that's what you meant like
how many times he was like no shiv's out
roman's out they're not prepared they're
not ready or whatever he needs one of
them to kill him he doesn't even realize
that that's true
great observation and then he did it and
now he's like
at war yeah he's like i'm not gonna go
down easy yeah i mean but yeah you're
right that was the only way he was gonna
give up the company that's the only rite
of passage you have to [ __ ] take him
out yeah
yeah he doesn't want anyone to ask for
it no
yeah that's going to be the this season
when kendall [ __ ] that's why i picked
jerry too
sorry yeah yeah because she didn't
because she's the [ __ ] she's a
pushover he knows that he can just still
pull the strings yeah you know what we
could do
is we could watch
william shatner's full speech that he
meant to make
in the last episode uh we watched his
like when he got off the blue origin
ship or whatever and he'd just been to
space and he was describing to jeff
bezos how it felt and in the middle of
his like revelations
jeff bezos cut him off
and we joked about that for like 15 to
20 minutes cut his ass off and we didn't
let him say anything exactly and we
found out there's a full recording of
actual his actual impressions and what
he wanted to say to jeff bezos yeah so i
thought it'd be nice maybe we could like
watch this because jeff didn't give him
the time of day and we can yeah we'll
give will willie schatz tell us man tell
us
what you were feeling up in space
weightlessness
oh jesus
yo pause this can we get some champagne
could you get some champagne in here can
we get some champagne
there we go perfect perfect yeah i'll do
the honors
for sure
what are we celebrating dude i don't
know you can let will talk or whatever
but uh yeah let this go
oh my god hey it's too um
to another great moment house yeah oh
wow
oh it's another great moment house show
yeah it's another guys join our mindset
being so successful yeah thank you all
for listening and supporting our mindset
um
it's been and the live show was just
crazy
sorry i meant to pour you first no it's
fine yeah can we make him stop talking
yeah you can pause that is really
distracting
there we go that's for you cheers yeah
one day he'll get that story out
that's good what were you talking about
um the live show no honestly
we should damn
we forgot to say it in the main
if you watch the live show and you're
listening on the bonus want to give a
big gas thank you yeah to watch the live
show which is
way more
way more than we did on the last one and
so
dope that we could pull that off can't
wait for the next one honestly so thank
you same same i feel like we're
yeah it's like we're like pioneering a
new
type of
content i don't know it's like we just
like took a risk on this yeah it just
seems to really work and i i'm having a
[ __ ] blast doing this
it just it feels good because
i feel like we're being creative about
it and it feels like because you know
you know i feel like we're at the point
where
so much of it
i feel like so much of what we do is
it's like partially routine it's like
yeah there's creativity but it's also
like
you're leaning into what you know works
yeah and this we don't know if it works
yeah we've only done it twice
so yeah it just feels new and it feels
like we're taking risks and like that
that part of it i think is the dopest
part yeah and to you know it's like
all the early [ __ ] that we did like
crossing your fingers like uh i think
this one's gonna this might hit like
just that feeling it's
feels good it's a rush yeah definitely
so thank you guys if you watched it
mm-hmm it was a good ass time
you